[Music]
have you ever wondered what is inside
your dental plaque
probably not but people like me do I'm
an archaeological geneticist at the
Center for evolutionary medicine at the
University of Zurich and I study the
origins and evolution of human health
and disease by conducting genetic
research on the skeletal and mummified
remains of ancient humans and through
this work I hope to better understand
the evolutionary vulnerabilities of our
bodies so that we can improve and better
manage our health in the future there
are different ways to approach
evolutionary medicine and one way is to
extract human DNA from ancient bones and
from these extracts we can reconstruct
the human genome at different points in
time and look for changes that might be
related to adaptations risk factors and
inherited diseases but this is only one
half of the story the most important
health challenges today are not caused
by simple mutations in our genome but
rather result from a complex and dynamic
interplay between genetic variation diet
microbes and parasites and our immune
response all of these diseases have a
strong evolutionary component that
directly relates to the fact that we
live today in a very different
environment than the ones in which our
bodies evolved and in order to
understand these diseases we need to
move past studies of the human genome
alone and towards a more holistic
approach to human health in the past but
there are a lot of challenges for this
and first of all what do we even study
skeletons are ubiquitous they're found
all over the place but of course all of
the soft tissue has decomposed and the
skeleton itself has limited health
information mummies are a great source
of information except that they're
really geographically limited and
limited in time as well
coprolites are fossilized human feces
and they are actually extremely
interesting you can learn a lot about
ancient diet and intestinal disease but
they are very rare so too
to to address this problem I put
together a team of international
researchers in Switzerland Denmark and
the UK to study a very poorly studied
little-known material that's found on
people everywhere it's a type of
fossilized dental plaque that is called
officially dental calculus many of you
though may know it by that term tartar
it's what the dentist cleans off of your
teeth every time that you go in for a
visit and in a typical dentistry visit
you may have about 15 to 30 milligrams
removed but in ancient times before
tooth brushing up to 600 milligrams
might have built up on the teeth over a
lifetime and what's really important
about dental calculus is that it
fossilizes just like the rest of the
skeleton it's abundant in quantity
before the present day and it's
ubiquitous worldwide we find it in every
population around the world at all time
periods going back tens of thousands of
years and we even find it in
Neanderthals and animals and so previous
studies had only focused on microscopy
they looked at dental calculus under a
microscope and what they had found was
things like pollen and plant starches
and they'd found muscle cells from
animal meats and bacteria and so what my
team of researchers what we wanted to do
is say can we apply genetic and
proteomic technology to go after DNA and
proteins and from this can we get better
taxonomic resolution to really
understand what's going on and what we
found is that we can find many commensal
and pathogenic bacteria that inhabited
the nasal passages and mouth we also
have found immune proteins related to
infection and inflammation and proteins
and DNA related to diet but what was
surprising to us and also quite exciting
is we also found bacteria that normally
inhabit upper respiratory system so it
gives us a virtual access to the lungs
which is where many important diseases
reside and we also found bacteria that
normally inhabit the gut and so we can
also now virtually gain access to this
even more distant organ system that from
the skeleton alone has long decomposed
and so by applying ancient DNA
sequencing
and protein mass spectrometry
technologies to ancient dental calculus
we can generate immense quantities of
data that then we can use to begin to
reconstruct a detailed picture of the
dynamic interplay between diet infection
and immunity thousands of years ago so
it started out as an idea is now being
implemented to turn out millions of
sequences that we can use to investigate
the long term evolutionary history of
human health and disease right down to
the genetic code of individual pathogens
and from this information we can learn
about how pathogens evolve and also why
they continue to make us sick and I hope
that I have convinced you of the value
of dental calculus and as a final
parting thought on behalf of future
archaeologists I would like to ask you
to please think twice before you go home
and brush your teeth
[Applause]
you
[Music]